[Applause]
the ethiopian capital has raised a brand
new army
men and women from all walks of life who
will soon be sent to the
front we found them at their first
parade at a school in addis ababa one of
11 such events held across this
sprawling city
so far they've received two days of
training and they don't have guns or
gear
but that didn't matter to the crowd
who roared on their neighbors preparing
for war
[Applause]
then cheered on the man who asked them
to fight
abi ahmed they cry the name of the
country's prime minister
last year he promised to eliminate the
tplf the leaders of the region of tigre
but it would prove a miscalculation
now tplf fighters are advancing on the
capital
ethiopia will prevail said this speaker
calling for the city's defence
[Applause]
[Applause]
yet it is the residents of this african
mega city who may prove a bigger
obstacle to the tplf than these would-be
fighters
there's nothing
forced there's nothing put on about
their support for the government and for
abby ahmed and it does make you wonder
how the tplf
would hold this city
occupy them because
they don't want them
residents don't want international
journalists here either they're
regularly accused of backing the enemy
we are fighting with the tplf in france
and we are fighting the international
community with propaganda they are also
fighting us with a false propaganda who
is who is fighting you with propaganda
like the
the
medias
who are managed by the
intelligence centers so there's there's
an international conspiracy to put the
tpl out in power of course
as the fighting draws closer to the
capital city the powers of the police
have been increased with a six-month
state of emergency
and an auxiliary force of citizen
officers now patrol the streets in
support
they have little training no authority
in law but they've been told to protect
the city and they told us they're on the
lookout for the tpla
have you found
any members of the tplf
but there are no hearings no charges or
trials and the majority of those
detained are tigrans
the un says more than a thousand have
been locked up in the past two weeks
but a prominent to graham told us that
number is far far higher
you can't
you can't use your language outside if
you use you'll be detained you'll be
taken
all are considered as the
failures
whether you have other ideas or
political opinions blah blah you'll be
considered as tibetans
there is comfort in numbers in this
uncomfortable city as the war creeps
closer to home
but the ethnic divisions in this
troubled nation will prove difficult or
impossible to bridge
john sparks sky news in addis ababa
[Music]